back to developments in jerusalem now
where hamas has reportedly fired several
rockets into israel
after their deadline passed for israeli
police to withdraw
from temple mount at the israeli
parliament the knesset has reportedly
been evacuated it's the holy month of
ramadan right now so we've had days of
clashes
at some of the holiest sites in
jerusalem let's say let's bring in danny
danon the former permanent
representative
of israel to the united nations good to
see you today do you think um
as we understand now the latest news
coming in hamas is now reportedly
attacking
israel do you think this could have been
avoided if perhaps israel had taken a
less hard-line approach over the last
few days to the unrest in jerusalem
on the contrary i think what we saw in
the last 24 hours
the israeli government is trying to
appease
the rioters at the beginning they
decided not to allow
jews to come and pray on the temple
mount only muslim
later that day they decided to cancel
a rally uh of judah want to celebrate
the unification of jerusalem
and still what we are getting in return
is
more violence more sweat and this is a
provocative by hamas by the palestinian
authority
it is all planned in advance it is not
spontaneous
it began a few weeks ago when president
abbas
announced that he will not have the
elections in the pa
and he started to incite against israel
using again jerusalem the holy site in
jerusalem
it is unfortunate to see that all over
again the leaders of the palestinian
choosing to incite rather than to
negotiate but mr mr mr dan i'm sorry
you choose the word in sight and you
also use the word provocative just
within the last 24 hours more than 300
palestinians have reportedly been
injured including 14 children one child
is dead
the palestinian red crescent says seven
people at least are now in a critical
condition
do you think in any way here israeli
police have used excessive force
absolutely not and let's speak about it
why those people were wounded
because they threw rocks on their
innocent
jews they actually used rocks from the
temple mount
to the holy site of the western wall and
when we speak about freedom of religion
it's not freedom for riots or violence
yes we allow muslims to pray
christians and jews it is unacceptable
that there will be freedom of religion
only to muslims in the old city of
jerusalem we have to guarantee
that there is freedom for all religions
and if someone is actually
exercising violence against others we
will use force
to allow everybody freedom of religion
but you you don't think mr donald that
so when it comes to the use of force or
excessive force i mean you
you said the palestinians are using
rocks the idf are using machine guns
so we are not using a machine guns we
have other means
to deal with the demonstrations we are
trying to minimize
the casualties but yes well i don't know
if you
show the audience the pictures when a
car of a
jewish family was almost clinched today
on their way to praying on the western
wall
the police have to come intervene and
save those people
so it's not about people who are
actually being wounded
by a peaceful demonstration those are
people
who are using rocks and molotov
cocktails
in order to assault the innocent jews
who are coming to pray in jerusalem
and the obligation of the police force
is to protect
everybody in the old city so it is a
provocation
it is a coming from incitement of the
leader of the palestinian
i'm calling here to all sides to to
allow
everybody to pray and to peacefully
continue to live in jerusalem
you don't hear the same voices coming
from the palestinian leaders
well mr daniel we are here in iit
international we're showing lots of
pictures of the violence happening
in various parts of jerusalem gaza and
the west bank so you asked if we were
showing the pictures we are
showing the pictures absolutely uh but
does it does it um concern you at all i
mean you know israel's biggest ally in
the west that that of the united states
is urging was ex asking people to
exercise restraint
urging caution and to de-escalate the
situation
don't you think both sides should be
responsible for de-escalating the
situation i mean okay you've got israel
you've got the palestinians as well but
it should be both sides
trying to find some sort of uh equal
status here don't you think
so i agree with you on the first part we
do want to see
the escalation we are saying it and we
act accordingly and i mentioned the
compromise that we did
in the last 24 hours but you cannot call
it both sides
you don't have both sides here you have
a terrorist organization like hamas
who only few minutes ago fired a rocket
into jerusalem
on innocent israeli civilians and you
have a peaceful country like israel
so you cannot use that language on both
sides and i tell you very seriously
tonight
if hamas will actually continue to
attack our cities
and our communities we will retaliate
we will not allow them to challenge our
willingness
and i can assure you that we have the
mean to to
retaliate and i would advise the hamas
leaders
to think twice before sending rockets
into our cities